major breakthrough in the hunter Biden
investigation after months of
stonewalling Republicans finally getting
their hands on suspicious bank records
pertaining to President Biden's family a
top GOP lawmaker claims one of the docs
reveals that a previously unnamed Biden
family member got a cut of a three
million dollar payment from a Chinese
Energy company two months after Joe
Biden left the vice presidency
they started wiring money to Biden
family members plural and there were
three different Biden family members
that received a cut from that three
million dollars including a new Biden
family member that's never before been
included in any of these investigations
so judge what do you think that was the
threat from the House Republicans about
the hearings that made the treasury
Department turn over these wires I'd
like to think so Dana but the truth is
in this day and age I don't think anyone
on the left is afraid or cow towels to
the law or to a subpoena or any of that
stuff I think that chances are someone
may have already had this someone may
have leaked some of it but look this is
a treasure Trove of information for a
prosecutor you know we just saw the
Murdoch trial right it was totally
circumstantial evidence this is not just
circumstantial we have eyewitness
evidence that along with this additional
circumstantial evidence points to the
big guy Bob olinski testifying about Joe
and we're talking millions of dollars
and no one to this day to my
satisfaction has shown how Joe Biden
whose wife is a teacher and he's been in
government his whole life is able to
have two beach houses a regular house
and the lifestyle that he has Jesse this
Revelation that a third Biden family
member we don't know who it is
that to me is pretty explosive news Well
we think it's Jimmy Biden's wife Jimmy
the chin we call him on prime time so
this would be lady chin or chinette and
she's been involved in the Biden family
business for quite some time and so she
looks like a little bit of a cut out so
if you send the money to her and then
she sends it to other people I mean it's
really Dopey to do that but it looks
like they got caught cold and now
yellen's the cover-up's over you can't
cover this thing up too much more but
Comer told me last night that he's only
looked at One Bank they've used 12 to 13
Banks the Biden family and he's only
looked at One bank so he's got banking
records from Just One bank and he's
already seeing stuff that doesn't look
right so once he gets all of the banking
records and all the suspicious
International wire transfers think about
it Dana if six million dollars comes
into the Biden family bank accounts a
month after Biden's the vice president
what was that work for and when was that
work done well they can't show anything
that they did there's no building they
built there's no product they sold
so what was it for and it was obviously
for work being done while Joe was vice
president AKA abroad do you think
Jessica some of this is why the Obama
Administration officials were emailing
amongst themselves expressing concern
about what was happening with Hunter
potentially
I have and thank God been consistent
from the beginning just put it all out
there whatever whatever has to happen
um and you know when they asked all of
the other candidates the Democratic
candidates well you know would this be
okay in your Administration they all
said no that your kids wouldn't be able
to do that Elizabeth Warren was most
forthcoming about it and said it sounds
like it's it's an Ethics violation and
we'll see where it goes so I'm happy for
them to have whatever it is and if it
turns out that this
web of entanglements or conspiracy
whatever Jesse is weaving and you mean
money payments to the Biden family no
but there's more wouldn't you say like
and there was a big diamond and then
there was well there was Chinese that's
what I'm saying there are a lot of deals
and now it's it's probably one of his
girlfriends okay okay so Greg there's a
sentiment out there from some that it's
been five years there's no indictment so
just drop it I don't think I'm not I'm
not for that no no what are you for only
idiots say that Dana and you're no idiot
I will say this though there is
something wrong with me I used to get
super excited about these stories you
know what I'm saying you hear a hunter
you go oh it's going to be good it's
going to be good but when you start
doing drugs and the drug is Hunter Biden
you start to develop a tolerance for it
right because you know become jaded to
the skullduggery you've got meth you got
crack you got hookers you got bribes you
got guns you got influence pedaling
he has flooded The Zone with so much
abuse that you end up conveniently
ambivalent right that's our press work
they're like ah you know that's
basically look you know we know he's a
junkie blah blah blah blah blah But the
irony is that they worked so hard to
find this stuff in the Trump family and
now they got it they got all this
influence peddling all this corruption
and it's like ah you know he's got
problems but it does show you that
there's a certain lie about the Biden
being you know a dedicated civil servant
Joe Biden you would be too if you knew
the perks and the payouts and the
payoffs you get it's a Lush Life it
really is you know oh you only get a
couple hundred grand a year but you
wouldn't believe the freebies and then
when you retire it's not just a golden
parachute it's like you know it's China
Ukraine Russia Romanian parachutes
filled with money
maybe I am excited by it yeah I talked
myself into it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else